regardez ça la regarde et ce à quatre
cent mille abonnés 400000 vous êtes 400
mille quatre cent mille mais c'est
beaucoup de personnes il ya beaucoup de
monde quand même à 400 milles c'est
assez dingue
enfin quand j'ai commencé ma chaîne j'ai
commencé à faire mes premières vidéos
vraiment c'était fin 2016 tout début
2017 souvenez vous un peu souvenez-vous
complètement fin 2016 je commence à
publier mais toute première vidéo même
si j'ai créé ma chaîne quelques temps
avant tu mettais des bricoles mais
c'était pas vraiment ça j'ai commencé à
créer fin 2016 mes deux premières vidéos
me dire je faire une vidéo tous les
jours 2010cette s'est déroulé cette
année 2010 est mon on est à peu près
combien on est dix mille et quelques
abonnés j'attaque 2000
8 nous sommes douze mille abonnés quand
je décide de partir au csa vegas est de
faire de la tec une vidéo tous les jours
une vidéo tous les jours c'était dingue
j'ai partie les débuts 2018 pour arriver
il ya deux ans quasiment jour pour jour
le 28 novembre 2010 huit cent mille
abonnés c'était le jour mon anniversaire
c'était no 10 ans de couple avec justin
c'était aussi le jour où je passais les
cent mille abonnés c'était il ya deux
ans aujourd'hui on est quatre cent mille
sur la chaîne c'est absolument
incroyable
ensuite y'a eu quoi c'était été c'était
au mois d'août 2010 9 200 mille abonnés
trois cent mille abonnés c'était cette
année c'était au mois de mars quand
c'était pendant le confinement mars 2020
hélas le 22e droit on est bien on est
loin devant le 20 novembre je sais plus
quelle journée le 20 novembre
aujourd'hui le 20 novembre 2020 eh bien
on est quatre cent mille vous êtes
caleçon mille abonnés sur la chaîne ça
me paraît assez incroyable donc voulait
par cette vidéo pour vous remercier
parce que c'est grâce à vous c'est vous
qui êtes là qui venait visionner les
vidéos qui vous intéressent à la tech
qui venaient découvrir
et bien tout ce que j'ai à vous proposer
de divers et variés et qui me suivaient
dans les aventures que ce soit sur de la
découverte de produits sont les
aventures plus personnel vous ai déjà
parlé d'histoire un petit peu plus
personnel j'en ferai peut-être
et voilà donc cesser tout ça c'est pour
vous je voulais vous remercier c'est
grâce à vous c'est un petit moment je
voulais partager avec vous alors là je
regarde maintenant plus loin et je
regarde je me dis que allez je vais pas
dire de bêtises 2021 dans le premier
saut neige 2021 si tout se passe bien et
que je bosse bien on devrait passer les
cinq cent mille abonnés audrey passé le
2 millions assez incroyable et puis
j'espère qu'avant la fin 2021
on va passer les 600 mille abonnés pour
continuer à progresser voilà j'ai plein
d'idées j'ai plein de faisans tête plein
de choses que j'ai envie de faire en
plus ce qui est assez dingue et je me
faisais la réflexion de deux jours on
est en train de travailler sur ma chaise
je suis quasiment avec vidéo sur ma
chaîne 1000 vidéos sur ma chaîne 400
mille abonnés c'est c'est dingue c'est
un peu n'importe quoi quand même vous
conviendrez ces chiffres la donne le
tournis et après attendait c'est même
pas touché le nombre de vues je crois
que le nombre de vues gas salut mon
incroyable je vais pas faire comme sur
cette vidéo je fais pas de montage pour
le public comme ça regardez le nom
de vue c'est ouf ça c'est à 5 très
attendu que passe un peu un petit point
foyer truc on a tout 60 millions de vues
on est à 60 millions 300 dates à 1665
vue pour être très précis
voilà ça je l'aurais jamais cru lorsque
j'ai créé la chaîne bien longtemps et
lorsque j'ai commencé à faire ses vidéos
fin 2016 fin 2016
400000 est bonne aujourd'hui c'est
dingue merci à vous merci tout mon coeur